Unmanned aerial vehicle project at x,
which we call wing houses.
It's aspiration to remove the bulk of
the remaining friction from how we move
physical things around in the physical
world,
particularly the so called last mile
problem.
If you look at the history of how
physical things have been moved around
in the physical world,
every time a chunk of the remaining
friction was removed from that process,
boats,
planes,
trains,
the automobile,
the Pony Express,
the mail system.
Every one of these things.
As we got more organized and removed
cost and complexity from how physical
things got moved around in the world,
the world became so different that it
was impossible beforehand to even
predict how different and how much
better it would be.
On the other side of that introduction,
we take for granted the remaining
friction as though it's natural and will
continue forever.
If you could have anything that would
fit in a breadbox brought to you within
one or two minutes,
you still have to pay for the thing
that's in the bread box,
but it could be brought to you nearly
for free.
Then our world would be radically
different.
Those batteries that are sitting in a
drawer in your house or apartment right
now,
discharging you have those batteries.
You're wasting the planet because you
think you might need a few of those
batteries before they fully discharge on
some Christmas morning or something.
But if you believed you could have any
battery,
any shaped a battery you want just in
the moment you need it,
you wouldn't bother holding all those
batteries.
You probably have a hammer in your house
or apartment.
Why do you have that hammer?
You almost never use it and we all have
to have a hammer for the occasional
moment when we want the hammer,
but we could probably share one hammer
around 10,000 of us.
Think how much richer the world would be
if we could have that.
How are we going to make it so that you
could have the hammer just appear within
a moment or two when you want it.
You say,
I want to hammer you,
get a cup of coffee at the most and the
hammers there and our proposal for how
to do that is that you can make small
vehicles that fly through the air
quietly and very safely and bring to you
whatever you want.
Our prediction is that at first society
will adopt these for the use of
delivering food.
Food is something that almost everybody
uses and that they use on a very regular
basis.
There's already a a very robust food
delivery market and people express an
interest in having a lot more to them
with respect to food.
So that is likely to be the early
adoption of this technology,
but the long run promise of being able
to move things around in inside of
cities and the suburban areas in
particular without having to create more
traffic congestion without the carbon
footprint that comes from large trucks
moving packages around without the sound
and safety problems produced by large
trucks moving around our city.
All of those problems can be solved by
flying what you want,
what you need right now to you through
the air.
We're public about the fact that we did
more than a thousand flights last year
in wing,
and I would like to see,
um,
at least a hundred times that many this
year and 100 times as many of the year
after that.
And,
and I don't think that that's a at all
out of the question,
there are regulatory conversations to be
had and demonstrations of safety to be
proven as we step through this process
in the United States and in other
countries.
And it's important that we push hard on
the technology,
but also work thoughtfully and
responsibly with the regulators to
demonstrate the safety and to build
their confidence in what we're doing as
we take each incremental step.